uh
hi everybody
and uh welcome to the
to the last uh day of the workshop
uh we are very excited to have uh
movies hart the director of the max
black institute
for intelligent systems
uh giving a talk uh to us today
i think really uh somehow
being the the organizer for this
workshop it feels like i'm announcing
the adventures we have really
quite the the assembly of like uh top
researchers in this area
but really uh this list will not be
complete without mortgage
or it's someone who has been uh working
very actively
to somehow we define the way we think
about computation and uh
intelligent systems from the perspective
of
social science and society
and introducing a new powerful concept
like performative predictions and many
other ideas that we've already been
seeing in this workshop
and we're very very excited to have him
and even happy to have you in person
thank you so much maurice please thanks
so much i guess really appreciate it um
pleasure to be here and see so many of
you in person um i'm gonna be talking
about the invisible hand of prediction
uh which is a title that'll make
increasingly more or less sense as i go
along in this talk so uh you'll see
um this is based on joint works with uh
mina jagadissan i got that right this
time uh celestine mendel dunner uh juan
carlos for doma and diana gernick and
there are three of them are in the
audience so uh
and i'll still practice okay so uh three
out of four it's strong for me okay so
um
yeah so okay three of them are in the
audience and uh we'll be able to correct
any mistakes i make so that's good
um so the starting point for um you know
my talk is the observation
that a whole lot of the discussions
we're having today the debates about
algorithms are about sort of the causal
effects of algorithmic predictions okay
so we're interested in things like how
recommendations and ads shape
preferences and consumptions
how selection rules uh incentivize
individuals to adapt to either through
gaming
or
or manipulation or self-improvement
various mechanisms um we heard a lot
about forecasts in this workshop um and
they can influence obviously behavior
and interventions um and then there are
risk scores deployed in uh consequential
uh you know settings in this country and
elsewhere that changed life trajectories
uh sometimes drastically so um all of
these are examples of causal effects of
algorithmic predictions right things
were like predictions that we make have
some kind of downstream uh implications
and so uh this talk is about how
predictions steer how predictions steer
populations how they change populations
and how these are often sort of
invisible causal forces um that lead to
changes in the population given the
predictions that we make
i'm going to introduce or like you know
recap a framework for reasoning about
such uh predictions effectual
predictions and that's called
performative prediction okay and the
general conceptual framework to reason
about these things um that we developed
here a couple of years ago um and i'll
tell you and review some emerging
results and relationships to another
area
some of you have worked in including
myself called strategic classification
okay and then i'll transition into a new
um observation uh that we call
performative power and that's like a new
tool a conceptual tool um that's sort of
derived from performative prediction uh
for measuring power uh market power in
digital economies and i'll explain why i
think this is sort of a useful
uh complement to classical entry trust
machinery and why it brings something to
the table that i think classical tools
don't necessarily have or struggle with
okay
so let's start with the basics how do we
make predictions um you all know this we
represent a population of uh individuals
as a fixed distribution d over data
typically features x and an outcome
variable y that we're trying to predict
from x now our goal is to find a
predictor theta x that minimizes some
loss function uh on this distribution d
okay
and uh this leads to this notion of risk
that we're trying to minimize risk
minimization so risk of of a predictor
theta on a distribution d is just the
expected loss of theta x
on y
for random draw x y from the
distribution okay this is risk we're
typically trying to minimize that i'm
not going to talk about how but you've
all you're all aware of many tools in
supervised learning that minimize risk
okay what i draw your attention to
instead is the fact somewhat implicit in
the setup that the prediction cannot
influence the outcome variable okay and
it's sort of um
kind of obvious but it's because you
sample x and y at the same time okay so
y is determined when x is determined
there's no chance that anything derived
from x can influence y
because you imagine that you had sampled
them at the same time okay
so uh you know supervised learning is
never is always sort of static right in
the sense that the outcome uh cannot be
influenced by anything you do with the
features okay in other words in
particular we ignore the cause effects
of prediction it's a little bit funny
that all the issues we have with
prediction are sort of about the causal
effects of prediction but the main
way we reason about prediction
supervised learning
is uh ignoring that it doesn't have a
way of coping with that
okay so recognizing this issue and you
know this happened like a long time ago
this reckoning and especially economics
and finance in the 70s but failure to
take into account causal effects of
predictions is dangerous leads to all
sorts of problems in policy and
forecasting
often goes by goodhart's law who stated
this in the context of financial policy
that if you actually use predictors or
statistical regularities to make policy
uh you know you try to control you try
to steer using statistics um these
patterns that you were trying to use
often disappear okay it's also closely
related to lucas critique in the context
of macroeconomics uh who observed that
you know macroeconomic policy making or
policy uh you know problems can uh
disrupt the statistics that motivate
their policy okay
so recognizing these uh these issues um
we uh proposed performance prediction as
a way to extend supervised learning just
enough to be aware of the causal
predictions of the predictor and so the
way this works is uh we introduced the
notion of performativity or it's
actually not a new notion but we
introduced it to the context of uh
supervised learning and we postulate
that upon deploying a model theta so
when the firm or institution deploys a
model theta um
the population changes in response to
that model from the original
distribution d to a new distribution d
theta
okay so d theta is what we call the
distribution map and the distribution is
allowed to depend on the model that was
deployed
okay and the idea of this d theta uh
distribution d theta is that it captures
kind of the
aggregate macro level change to decision
rule okay so it's the population change
the population level change resulting
from a decision rule and of course
there's some modeling involved here you
need to fix the time horizon and and so
on but conceptually it's the change that
results from uh the deployed model
so this leads to this extension of risk
called performance risk where you
evaluate a predictor theta on this
distribution d theta that now depends on
uh you know theta itself so it's a bit
of a moving target problem so you draw a
sample from
you know x y from this distribution d
theta and you look at the loss of theta
x on y and now here importantly in this
expectation that is with respect to the
distribution d theta okay
so
x and y is still drawn at the same time
just from d theta yeah yeah yeah
um but
you see
basically the distribution had a chance
to depend not just on theta x but on the
whole model theta right so in particular
could have you know already like
uh it could already depend on
uh you know the y could depend on theta
x
because the distribution d theta depends
on theta and all its prediction that it
makes
you can make it such that y depends on
theta x
that's an important point so it does
have that dependency you can you can
create that okay so you can
easily model things where y depends on
theta x so for instance y could be
a biased coin toss with uh you know bias
theta x right that would be easy to
express as abstractly as such a
distribution
good question
okay and so um
just as a note to get you thinking about
this in practice performativity often
shows up as some kind of distribution
shift after deploying okay so you're a
recommender system you ship a new model
it starts making new recommendations
people watch different things and you're
like oh the distribution has shifted
right but of course that's like that's a
sign of performativity okay your
predictions are changing the world and
the training consumption
okay so there are two uh different
solution concepts that this leads to
once you introduce the simple change the
first one is optimality or performative
optimality and the second one is
stability so let me start with the first
so model theta star is performatively
optimal
if it minimizes the performance risk
okay so it's just uh a minimizer of the
performative risk okay that's all that's
that's pretty straightforward but it's a
complicated objective because it's sort
of moving target thing you're trying to
be good on the distribution that your
model entails okay so it's uh it's
uh this is what performance optimality
says okay
and so contrast this with a slightly
different condition of stability
where we say that a mod theta star is
performatively stable if theta star
minimizes
uh risk
while holding the distribution fixed
that results from it
okay
so you you just hold the distribution
fixed that results from your model and
you sort of minimize one more time okay
you're at some you cost some
distribution to manifest and now you
minimize
and you see what happens okay and so a
stable point is a fixed point of risk
minimization okay so you're in some
distribution you minimize risk
if you don't change you know if you get
the model that you already had then you
have a stable point
okay so stable point is a fixed point of
risk minimization
if you have a stable point you do risk
minimization you don't change you you
stay at the same model or at least it's
something that's equivalent to your
model has the same risk
okay so stable points the best way to
think about them is operationally your
recommender system if you train and your
loss doesn't go down or doesn't change
then you have a stable point
okay
here's another way to think about this
that will be particularly relevant for
this talk
i'm going to think of you know this kind
of performative optimality as a notion
of exposed optimality
okay so you successfully steered the
population towards a state that is
beneficial to you okay so you somehow
managed to find a d theta on which you
have low risk so x post after observing
the new distribution you somehow have
low risk right
so it's a notion of x post optimality
after the distribution manifested you're
good on that distribution
and i think of uh stability as a form of
ante optimality okay you sort of take
the distribution for whatever it is you
hold the distribution fixed these are
just the conditions that you observe you
observe the data and you just optimize
against the the conditions that you have
okay
so that you don't care about what
happens after
you're just optimizing
the distribution that you have
okay
yeah it's a little bit different um
[Music]
neither it is
uh you know here you're fixing it
here you're changing everything you can
take a ball
and then say that minimize over that
right so you could do something like um
you have to express it as a distribution
so let's say you try to express an
infinity ball you do something like you
sort of
you know uniform over an infinity ball
or something like that you can probably
like relate this to
uh notions like that yeah
i thought you motivated this earlier by
saying that the distribution changed in
response to the choice of theta yeah i
feel like the equilibrium or the
stability should be with respect to a
potentially changing distribution
i'm a little lost on it
um
so
um basically yeah if you think of this
as an equilibrium solution it's sort of
a one-sided notion right like if you did
one more step of risk minimization you
wouldn't you know you would move if
you're in a nearly stable state right
uh you could imagine swapping the
arguments that will give you different
equilibriums maybe this is what you're
getting at you could if you think about
it as a two-player game between the
distribution and the classifier
right
then this is sort of just a one-sided
equilibrium in that game where it's
stable with respect to the
the classifier
um it need not be stable with respect to
the distribution
i think this is kind of what you're
getting at i think you have to play a
game in mind where
this is not like a natural equilibrium
right this is not like simultaneously
um this is not an equilibrium when
they're single phases
although if d theta is like the best
response of the distribution to theta
then you get it yeah that's right yeah
so hold that thought that's going to be
relevant later if you know more about
what d theta is
then uh you get like
an equilibrium notion
okay so that's going to come up in a
second so maybe like hold that thought
for a second and um
but yeah i mean for now just think of it
as like a one-sided equilibrium with
respect to the classifier
okay that's what i call stable statement
okay so on this like notion of like x
post of the melody and steering versus x
ante optimality and optimizing there's
like a nice way to uh conceptualize this
this you know optimizing versus steering
that i think is very uh fundamental to
performative prediction
suppose we're in a world um given by a
baseline state theta zero that's like
maybe a past
um deployed model that uh the previously
deployed model and it gives us a
distribution d
um that is you know uh d theta zero so
it's like the distribution d resulting
from theta zero
and i can trivially write the
performative risk of a predictor theta
in this kind of like decomposition so
there's nothing going on here just write
it as the risk of theta on d
plus the risk of theta and d theta
performed risk minus uh you know the
risk of theta and d okay everybody
believes this fact right
this is the kind of theorems that prove
okay so um but i like these because they
get you sort of thinking in the right
way okay so here the way you should
think about this is that uh the first
term is the ex-ante risk okay it's how
well you you optimize against current
conditions think of theta zero as some
kind of like state of the economy uh
then the exante risk is how well you
respond to the state of the economy okay
that's exactly risk how well you
optimize in current conditions the
exposed advantage is what i call the
second term and this is how much you can
gain from steering right this is when i
take like x anti optimization as a
baseline and i imagine where i look at
how much better i can do by pushing the
distribution into a state i want d theta
okay
so this is kind of the exposed advantage
of this predictor theta it's like how
much does this predictor benefit from
having moved the population to d theta
okay
so uh and this is what i mean by this
decomposition if you want to minimize
performance risk the way to think about
it is you one thing you need to like
respond well to like existing conditions
and the other is you haven't need to
have an exposed advantage
okay that's kind of how you can think
about it
does it make sense
i mean
like you've described as an advantage
but intuitively would you actually think
of it as a disadvantage like i would
expect that second term
yeah it's negative but you know it's
sort of like uh it's you know loss is
something you want to minimize so an
advantage is like a negative term does
it make sense sure
you could also write it as like minus
and then some of the terms
there there's a big family of three arms
here
so um yeah but your observation is
correct like it is a negative term
that's that's correct
and it's over how much you can make the
law smaller by
playing around with this exposed term d
theta
that's the right way
yeah so keep in mind performance equals
excellent risk plus exposed advantage
right so here
like if you did the simple thing where
you're just tuning theta based on like
learning from b
then um it would be
right
so
like sometimes it could be positive
sometimes it could be negative yeah it's
just right it need not be negative like
you know if you're doing well it's
negative right but it needs to be
negative
okay this is like this could be positive
or negative
so okay just a good one
all right so the first uh the first
question uh you know you might have a
birthmark question about the setting can
we even find stable points okay so this
looks like a pretty terrifying objective
can we even find stable points in
general and generality okay and so
there's one way to try to do it since
stable points are the fixed point of
risk minimization you can just repeat
risk minimization you just play out the
fixed point iteration see what happens
okay so it's repeated risk minimization
practice that's sometimes called
retraining and sort of what a lot of
practitioners do just retrain your model
every day does that converge okay so
repeater risk minimization is the
following heuristic you find a model
theta that minimizes risk on the current
distribution uh then you deploy the
model and you observe a new distribution
d theta okay and you go on repeat
does it converge or not this is uh the
first sort of theorem we proved about
performance prediction with
honky and tiana and celestine a couple
years ago
and the informal theorem is that if
you're um
you have a smooth strongly convex loss
and an insensitive distribution map in a
sense that i'm going to make precise in
a second then repeated risk minimization
finds a performative stable point okay
so you converge under some uh strong
complexity assumption and smoothness
assumptions fairly strong but sort of
standard optimization assumptions but
strong convexity is kind of necessary
okay so there's something specific about
uh strong convexity for performativity
weak convexity is not enough okay so you
need strong convexity here to converge
okay
um and a little bit more detail uh you
need the loss function to be smooth beta
smooth and those are both arguments loss
functions two arguments you need it to
be gamma strongly convex
and
the distribution map has to be epsilon
sensitive and then you get this
geometric rate of convergence determined
by these three parameters and when i say
epsilon sensitive of d theta you know
what does it mean to be insensitive for
a distribution map it maps you know
a a parameter vector theta into a set of
distributions right
into the set of distributions so you
need some kind of probability metric
okay and the one we pick and the one
that's sort of the right thing for this
proof is the wasserstein metric or earth
merger distance so we look at the
western metric between d theta and d
theta prime and you want that to be at
most an epsilon times the distance and
parameter vectors that's what i mean by
insensitive so changes in your model
parameters don't change the distribution
arbitrarily
okay
so that's the that's the thing you need
to make this work
that sounds good
okay the proof is relatively short but
i'm not gonna go into it because it
talks kind of about something else but i
tell you that um this led to a number of
like uh nice results uh you know that
use similar assumptions so this epsilon
sensitivity was very helpful improving a
number of results the first one you saw
uh how retraining convert this to a
stable point uh you extended that to uh
stochastic optimization results there
was also nice paper out of uw by address
yaya ayats
yatsuki and zhao uh who had a nice uh
generalization of this um
then uh uh john miller jackie perdoma
tianjonic um you know had a result on
how to actually find optimal points not
just stable points um under assumptions
that kind of make the performative risk
convex so there are assumptions where
the whole performative risk becomes
convex and you can optimize it
so that was this paper there have been a
couple of papers maybe more at this
point about stateful and time varying
distribution shifts so what if like you
deploy a model and then your
distribution changes in multiple steps
where it changes as some like function
of time okay there's also a lot you can
do and you know again you can extend
these assumptions to these kind of
settings and then also see uh lillian's
uh lillian ratliff's talk on wednesday
for a number of results on performance
prediction in particular like an
interesting setting of multiplayer
performative prediction um that she
talked about okay so there's a whole a
lot of activity here that i'm very
excited about but there's still many
open problems uh in particular um things
i don't have good answers to is what
happens with over parameterized models
and prediction non-convex
losses and the uh the question that was
bothered people with this sort of what's
the kitchen sink approach to
performative prediction if you just
we're a deep learning person
i'm already being like mocked here for
like stating this again so um if what
you know if you had like if you thought
like a deep learning person had all the
resources in the world how would you
solve performance prediction right like
you mean
all the
like data all the features all the
computation all the you tell me yeah
so um
yeah whatever you want to throw in the
kitchen sink okay um
so yeah um
well i guess i'm
i'm a little
so when you say solve the problem are
you trying to find the stable point
because it's not clear to me that you
would want to state a stable point
necessarily like maybe the optimal thing
to do like for the world
is to have a classifier that's just
slightly off from the distribution that
it induces but that's like better for
everyone
excellent question so rob's asking a
great question is like normatively as
stable as a stable point in what we want
right uh or is optimality where we want
or some other thing and i think
connecting this to like welfare or
utility i think is really important
and that's another great open question
like how do you you know what is
actually good like if you had some like
notion of like social welfare right like
what what would actually be solutions
everyone have
friends and then
this seems to assume that you know the
model is that like a realist assumption
[Music]
but you know how the distribution is
going to change in response to
everything no so you don't right so this
is these this part of why um you know
this so in this repeated risk
minimization it's um it's in sort of an
experimental iterative
procedure right you but you don't
actually know what the distribution map
works
like
you just like deploy the model see what
happens deploy the model see what
happens so you can see some of the
figures you're thinking of are similar
to right right they could be in that
nature where you don't you don't have
like a model for the distribution family
you just kind of keep deploying and hope
that something good happens uh one
exception is this paper here that i
mentioned that has like parametric
assumptions on the distribution map or
some kind of distribution family
assumptions that's also like a good
question like what happens if you have
you know
statistical assumptions on distribution
yeah
i'd like to go back to that discussion
about differentiating this from the
distribution
like we're saying so because theta being
introduced in the world is just one of
the many ways the distribution right
and so
i so my question is kind of like if you
have any intuition with when is this
framework
more adequate to reading about your
problem in the sense that
like that you know that is going to be
the main thing or not just one thing you
just are
ready to vote right right so everyone is
asking excellent question right so um
when you deploy models right and you
look at what happens there's like this
causal suit of like things that happen
right there's like time that passes
weekdays you know uh natural drift all
sorts of things and then there's the
causal effect of your model right so
there's all sorts of stuff uh happening
and for this model everything else
that's happening is exogenous and you
only look at the causal effect of the
model and for this to kind of make sense
you sort of want to be
in a setting where the model deployment
is kind of the biggest element in the
room okay so you you know this is kind
of like the the main thing that's
happening so you know if you look at
you know maybe it's a small time scale
like you're a recommender system you're
deploying it you know you're looking at
one week you know one week of traffic
you updated your model and you think
that mostly the distribution shift that
you're seeing is due to like the new
predictions that you're making there are
other settings where that's probably not
the case right and so um we'll come back
to like settings where or like how much
performativity we expect there is in
different settings and that's actually
going into the second part of the talk
so we'll go into that thingy although
presumably this repeated risk
minimization stuff
would be the thing you'd want to do even
if you have a mixture right because like
you care about i mean it could be a
thing you want to do right because it'll
deal with the exogenous stuff just fine
yeah so that's another uh good
observation yeah so um
the repeated risk minimization is
interesting people do anyway right so in
some sense this results like descriptive
it's saying like if the distribution
shift happened from
you know we're caused by your model it
would it would convert and trade and you
can probably also throw in like extra
noise terms or whatever right maybe
something you know will still work yeah
creative result you need new samples
each time you take a step
no so in the repeated risk movements you
do need new samples because the
distribution is new so you kind of
imagine that you collect
new observations after every model with
one
so did you mention how many examples you
need um
yeah i mean this is i i was talking
about repeated risk minimization so it's
just like i'm like talking about the
population dynamic and then you can
relate that to fine example either
through like stochastic optimization
like you do here you get slightly
different convergence rates or you can
do like you know just uh uniform
convergence and you know argue it that
way okay but this is sort of these are
the two options yeah all right let me
get go ahead and i'm excited about the
interest here and you know should look
at all these papers and and think about
this um there's kind of um
an important transition i want to make
which is moving from this macroscopic
perspective about like population
aggregate level changes to uh more of a
micro uh perspective and so i said that
performed predictions about these
population dynamics and most positive
results are finding stable points but
from this like aggregate perspective it
seems to be pretty hard to kind of find
optimal points okay it's kind of
delicate and you know if you think about
these population dynamics a difficult
thing to do okay and so is there perhaps
like a micro perspective by which you
sort of make stronger assumptions about
where this distribution shift is coming
from that give you a result um you know
in turn like better or stronger results
okay and the answer is yes and we'll see
that and in fact many of you already
familiar with it because this is the
setting of strategic classification
where you assume that the distribution
shift d theta comes from strategic
behavior of individuals trying to adapt
to the decision rule okay so in like
performance prediction you didn't have
this interpretation it could be anything
right um but here in strategic
classification you assume that there's
some kind of individual that um
strategizes against your decision rule
and changes their features uh as a
result uh you know of your your
predictor okay and when you uh go down
this route it makes sense to pick some
of the standard econ assumptions or what
i call standard microfoundations which
is that you assume a rational utility
utility maximizing agent you assume that
the agents are representative for the
whole population
and uh you assume that the agent
computes the best response to the
decision rule okay so these are kind of
the standard
assumptions that game theories or
algorithmic game theories like to throw
in when we model uh individual behavior
okay so we've all kind of gotten used to
these these assumptions
and there's also the route we took in a
paper several years ago number of
megiddo and christopher papua newsreel
and mary wooders where we introduced the
strategic classification model and
there's been a lot of work and so the
advantages of these standard mic
foundations are kind of clear um it
gives you like a precise
characterization of the distribution map
you now know analytically kind of like
what happens when you uh deploy a
classifier and as a result because of
this kind of analytical control that you
have now there are many ways to find
performative optima and in the setting
they're called stackelberg equilibrium
okay so like your classifier is optimal
with respect to the best response of the
agent that's a stackable equilibrium
and there's been all sorts of work
varying cost functions model families
approximate best response multiple
different cost functions online setting
and so on and all of these give you
positive results okay so there's um
there's actually a lot you can do with
these assumptions and i think we
understand relatively well now like all
the things you can derive and strategic
classification from these standard
assumptions
okay so the thing i want to keep you in
mind i want you to keep in mind this is
strategic classification is performative
prediction plus standard
microfoundations it's what happens when
you instantiate this general setup with
the standard assumptions the standard
agt assumptions about uh sort of user
behavior or like agent behavior
okay
in a recent paper we sort of um
you know pointed out some issues with
these standard microfoundations in the
context of strategic classification um
so this is what worked with um uh sales
team
so
enlar
the first observation is that you know
this aggregate response d theta that you
get in strategic classification
necessarily has discontinuities that you
don't necessarily observe in empirical
settings so basically the way this
always works is if you have some kind of
threshold rule and you have some budget
that agents have some kind of cost
they're willing to incur then everyone
who's within the cost of the threshold
will move up to the threshold and
exactly to the threshold and everyone
else will stay put so a d theta in the
setting would always look like this
right
um and that's obviously not something
you see that often i'll give you a few
examples one where you kind of see it
but most of the time you don't see this
sort of thing
the second thing that's kind of
concerning about these assumptions is
that any positive fraction of
non-strategic agents destroys the
existence of uh stable points okay so
the moment some people choose not to
strategize or don't have the ability to
strategize
you lose these kind of nice properties
and third these standard assumptions
lead to something that lead to solutions
that maximize a negative externality
called social burden so in some sense
they're most beneficial for the decision
maker and least beneficial for the
individual okay so
basically the price that positive
instances have to pay to be accepted is
maximized by these kind of assumptions
so they're maximally sort of uh you know
welfare minimizing right they're like
best for the institution but they're
extremely conservative and as a result
they maximize this burden on the
individual
okay
um i'll skip over the examples again
this is with me nine celestine i'll skip
over the examples where this happened
you can look at this paper
um and instead i want to move into the
second part of the talk there's been a
lot of discussion so i need to move on
um so what's you know uh
let's recap on performative right sorry
i hope i can convince you that once you
know this concept you sort of see it
everywhere right you can look at your
favorite prediction problem in the
social world and uh it's probably
performative okay and so if you're like
me you can even box yourself into the
corner where you would say uh with a
straight face that any social prediction
problem is performance okay so i would
make this claim and if you find like a
production prediction problem in the
social world that is not performative uh
you know let me know okay and so we saw
that performance prediction is sort of
fundamentally it's about this difference
between learning and steering learning
from a population versus steering in
population okay and so remember
performance risk equals x ante risk
which i interpret as learning or
optimization plus x post advantage which
i interpret as steering okay
so
this is where the invisible hand of
prediction comes in okay so if social
prediction is necessarily performative
as i would argue the question is still
how much okay and this is also
touched on this like how much is
uh how much are uh how performative are
the predictions that we make right if i
make
predictions as a professor in my office
and nobody listens right it's probably
not very performative okay
if i'm uh you know the central bank of
some government and make like you know
inflation forecasts probably highly
performative right
if i'm the only uh traffic routing app
around i'm probably highly performative
and if i like change traffic predictions
for people they probably go a different
route okay so you think about this and
you work out all these examples where
things are performative and you notice
that the strength of performativity
intuitively speaking depends on power
okay it depends on the power of the
institution or the firm or the
individual that makes the prediction
okay
so yeah the question is are we talking
about predictions or decisions um so in
the formal model they're true ancestors
right an informal model the
you know the the cause of power comes
from your model right it's like the
distribution depends on theta and it's
allowed to depend anything about data
including decisions that you make based
on data or predictions that you make it
could be a probability number that you
write on some website it could be like
the hard decision that you make right so
the setup generally accommodates like
anything that you do based on
on your model okay so it includes these
things um but yeah i mean i think it's
closer intuitively speaking to a
decision because you kind of wanted to
have some causal powers right
so
um and it shouldn't surprise you with
the benefit of hindsight that somehow uh
performativity is related to power
because like one uh in a dictionary
definition of power is literally the
capacity or ability to direct or
influence the behavior of others or the
course of events okay so it's not
surprising that
performs predictions some are related to
power and so then you can turn this
logic on its head and you can ask can we
use performativity to actually reason
about power to actually reason about the
power of predictive systems
okay
and so in particular i want to you know
get you thinking about this kind of
question when does a digital platform
have too much power or have monopoly
powers right the sort of typical
question you ask in in antitrust uh you
know regulation what does it mean for
one of these algorithmic platforms to
have too much power right like youtube
or facebook and so on and so digital
platforms are tricky for current
antitrust frameworks and it's kind of
interesting just in recent years there
were two major reports that really drove
from that point the first one is by the
stickler committee on digital platforms
i think jamie was involved in that as
one of the experts on the computer
science side and uh there are many
quotes that make this point but one of
them is pinpointing the locus of
competition can also be challenging
because the markets are multi-sided and
often ones with which economists and
lawyers have little experience this
complexity can make market definition
another hurdle to effective enforcement
right so market definition is an issue
here because like somehow these
platforms don't operate within like
classically recognize sort of market
boundaries right it's like very hard to
define like what kind of market they're
actually operating in is it the
advertising market or the media market
or the news market or whatever right so
what is the kind of market definition
you would even apply to these things
and uh there was a sort of counterpart
to this report by the european
commission um which had similar
conclusions it argued that there should
be less emphasis on analysis of market
definition and more emphasis on theories
of harm and identification and the
identification of anti-competitive
strategies so it said like maybe we
should like
you know forget like about these
market-based or market definition-based
frameworks and think more about how we
actually measure anti-competitive
patterns okay
and this is the kind of
issue
that we're responding to okay and this
is a proposal called performative power
it's with uh mina and celestine that
just appeared on the archive
i think yesterday it was no april fool's
joke right it's like meant to be serious
paper okay
so um it's on the archive you can look
it up and so the informal definition i'm
gonna make it uh formal in a second
is that performative power is the
largest change to a population that the
firm can cause with respect to given set
of actions and we think of these actions
typically as like models that have you
know predictive models that a platform
can deploy i'm going to give you several
examples but i want to say right away
that there's no need here for market
definitions firms prices equilibria or
anything like that which would go into
traditional frameworks for reasoning
about power it's just sort of about
directly about the causal power that a
firm has over a population with respect
to predictive models okay and that's
what we're going to try to try to
measure
this is very different from a
traditional anti-trust machine okay so
you don't need like a baseline
equilibrium you don't need like
you don't even know which firms are
involved in the market you don't need
prices or anything like that you do need
a population and a population definition
and you do need to sort of think about
what your actions are okay so let's um
go to the formal definition and then see
what we can do with it
the formal definition goes like this you
fix the population of participants
interacting with a firm and what your
units are i'll call them you um sort of
depends on what you're trying to do
where you're trying to like identify
anti-competitive patterns so you know
this could be uber drivers or it could
be content creators on youtube or it
could be you know customers on um your
restaurants on yelp right it could be
any number of things that you
instantiate this definition with and f
is a set of actions the firm can take
typically we think of these as a set of
predictive models that an algorithmic
platform can deploy okay
but it could be other actions and
sometimes we'll instantiate these
differently
and
i'm going to write z u as the data of
participant u okay so every participant
u
has a data vector
that are called z
and here's uh an important uh uh you
know construct uh let z subscript f of u
be a potential outcome representing the
data of participant u if the firm were
to take action f okay so the causal
counterfactual
potential outcome variable uh
representing the the data that would
uh manifest had the firm taken action at
okay
and so okay are these ingredients clear
and so this potential outcome these
could be random variables okay in
general or the the the potential outcome
could have a randomness in it
because the z is indexed by you i can
imagine that's just fixed vector ref can
we have like a running example maybe yes
absolutely i'll instantiate this in a
second let's just appreciate the bubble
definition and instantiate it okay
so um so we define the performance power
of a firm with respect to the population
action zach and potential outcomes as uh
you know the supreme overall reactions
of the expected distance between the
data of participant u
and the you know hypothetical data of uh
participant u under the action f
okay so the distance here is just a
metric over the space of data points it
doesn't have to be something fancy it
could be something like just uh you know
an absolute value or something like that
if you have uh if you have a single
feature that you're interested in and
the expectations taken over the random
participant you a random job a
participant
and the potential outcome randomness
okay
so this is the abstract definition
uh and let me go into an example to see
how to instantiate it
so again this performative power
supremum over actions of a firm expected
distance in
the you know current data and the
counter factual data that results from
the from the action
okay so first you choose your population
and units at one end of the power
relationship in my example i'm going to
choose restaurants in the united states
okay
and i'm going to as the platform i'm
going to choose yelp okay so this
example is about yelp i'm going to
choose yelp i'm going to choose
restaurants in the united states as my
population of interest
and i'm going gonna model actions uh you
know that are within reasonable agency
of the firm and i'm gonna take this as
the set of ranking models that yelp
could deploy okay so these are all the
things that you know yelp all the
scoring models that yelp has and could
deploy to rank uh you know or to rate um
you know um you know restaurants okay
and um you know finally you have to pick
the z
and this is you know uh you pick things
that you think are salient to the power
relationship and are sort of like
reflect the the well-being of the unit
okay so in this case i uh you know um
take wait times of the restaurant okay
how much business the restaurant has so
it's kind of like a proxy for how much
business business the restaurant is
getting
so look at yelp i look at restaurants in
the u.s i look at the set of scores that
yelp could deploy
and i uh look at how busy restaurants
are
okay
is that is that a an example that sort
of makes it clear
so here in this model you you assume
that z exists without the
without the field no but for instance
for social media
you may need a action to
have a feature here
that's a good point so um
think of the c you're asking why does
this z not have a subscript
right you could think of it as like kind
of the baseline data point which could
for instance be the result of the
current action that the firm plays okay
right so yeah i mean you could like
introduce an extra subscript here which
is like the current baseline state of
the world similar to how to perform the
prediction you could imagine that you
start out with some distribution and
move to somewhere this is
okay so the yelp example i'm actually
going to return to in a second um but
for uh you know
you know for now i want to just uh
convince you that this definition or
with a little bit of theory that this
definition is doing what it uh is
supposed to be okay
questions about this
yeah
where do you get zfu
um yeah it's a potential outcome
variable um you know you may not
necessarily be able to observe it right
but one thing you can see or like you
know you can in principle apply all
sorts of causal difference tools to get
this in an estimate of this right this
is essentially like a you know a
treatment effect right under this uh
intervention of f one thing you can do
for example is suppose you have data
before the firm deploys a model and data
after firm deploys a model that would be
one way of getting in but we'll see more
clever ways to estimate this in just a
second but conceptually for now you can
think of like having data before an
intervention and after an intervention
that's how you get it
and you don't notice that you don't need
it for every unit you just need the
average okay like we're looking at the
expected value here so you don't
necessarily just need this and you'll be
able to estimate it from standards
you can't estimate it from samples you
don't have to
know this for every unit
does that make sense yeah it just seems
to me that if you have that information
you could go back and get the market
equilibria or the prices or all the
things that you said were too hard to
get
oh no i disagree right because uh you
know let's say i give you uh you know
just like
um you know the wait times of like
you know yelp uh restaurants before and
after i deployed a model now give me a
market equilibrium
i don't see how
so you're not modeling anything about
the change in behavior the behavior of
the restaurant you're just observing
yeah so no from this alone i could
there's no way i could back out a market
definition
i'm just really observing like data
before and after some action and the
features could just be like one one
feature like
you know the wait times at the
restaurant or something like that
yeah so maybe saying something obvious
but these market definitions are useful
to the extent that an anti-trust
authority can actually operationalize
them
you know
an authority will never be able to
as an up to date well i thought no no we
first of all two ways okay do we have
the data um we'll see in a second like
in many cases yes we can get lower
bounds on this from like data we have
second
especially if you're thinking about
regulation this gives you like a
concrete thing to ask for right so yeah
you could operationalize this as like
let me run this experiment right
right that's kind of invasive so if
you've done an experiment on a platform
then you know it's like you could do
many things because if i could what's
not about whatever i just agree it's
just an ap test platforms run like a
millionaire test every day um i see that
but i never seen an authority like
asking a platform to run an a b test i
mean that's just not in the undead
debate uh it's too invasive this just
okay so if you have that mindset which i
i
uh may not know enough about entertains
to sort of judge but uh if you have that
mindset you can also estimate this from
observational data yeah
and i'll get into that in just a moment
especially if you have the cooperation
of the restaurants who might be the ones
who are making the claim about antitrust
exactly i think you can get that data in
a lot of cases i mean
i mean i think if i asked army nicely
who would let me run the cd experiment
no
uh
no okay maybe
we'll talk about that so you have a lot
of market power so first of all
experiment second observation so just
let me clear what the uh how this works
is right this is a carbon notion uh
there are two ways to go about it one is
experiment and the other is like you
know observational causal inference
right and both of these apply if you can
do an experiment great if uh you need
observational causal inference then we
can talk about how to do that and i will
in just a second
i don't understand why the definition is
based on a singular intervention or a
single gene i mean why is it not based
on
set of concurrent information
you still consider if i hadn't
interpreted on a single random
oh no this is like you you
the intervention is on the platform so
this is yelp deploying a new model which
simultaneously affects all restaurants
this is just like how that intervention
affects unity
so like f is the intervention the
intervention is sort of something that
platform does
and then there's like an effect that
intervention has on every unit
and that's this kind of partial fear
okay
and using different models
um you could think about that maybe that
corresponds to something interesting too
i haven't thought about it yeah it's a
good question okay so here's the key
property that this has
which is a theoretical property
and so basically low performative power
implies that the best the firm can do is
ex-ante optimization on current data
um and there's no gain from exposed
optimization
okay so uh let me uh state this claim
suppose we're in a world that is given
by a baseline state theta zero and this
goes back to your question right so
we're assuming there's some baseline
state uh given by theta zero theta zero
is a model
and let's suppose we uh we're an e firm
that's just doing uh you know supervised
learning in current conditions so we're
just running supervised learning against
current uh conditions uh this is the
theta supervised learning uh you know
solution
and then suppose we're a sneaky firm
that is doing a performative
optimization somehow it gets like the
performative optimum theta po okay then
i claim that the performance risk of the
supervised learning solution is upper
bounded by the performance risk of the
performative optimum plus the
performance power
okay
so in other words if the performance
power of the firm is low
you're essentially a price taker okay
the market gives you current conditions
and all you can do is optimize against
it
there's no gain from like
exposed steering okay there is a next
steering gives you nothing or very
little just something proportional to
your to your performative power
okay so basically what we're going to
see is that low performative power is a
conceptual
uh analog or alternative to competition
okay so low performative power is kind
of a proxy for competition and just like
in a competitive market you become a
price taker
under low performance power you
essentially become an optimizer
the only thing you can do is supervise
learning okay there's nothing more
clever you can do
so the problem is
yeah so
maybe this is obvious but is a firm
trying to minimize the risk where
they're trying to make money
very good yeah this is an excellent
question
more in detail so basically the way
firms actually operate is they might
solve some optimization problems and
then they uh deploy right or do an a b
test to you know estimate profit right
it's like very hard to like directly
optimize profit in the advertising
ecosystem right so basically you're
solving the circle this noob where it's
all like an optimization objective you
deploy to see how much money you're
actually making and so on right and so
you could talk about being performative
on the profit objective right and
there's a very good observation here
like are you trying to be performative
on the profit objective or in the
on the you know uh the supervised
learning objective right and there was a
difference right so you're kind of
hoping that by being performative on the
on the optimization objective you're
performing on the profit objective
but just like there's a can you know a
disconnect between optimization and
profit without performativity
there's a possibly even bigger
disconnect between optimization and
profit
um
in the performance setting and you can
think about one day's disconnect that's
that's a great question
good let's move on and this holds in
generality this is just like a general
property of performance power there's a
whole lot we you can say if you're
willing to like uh introduce micro
assumptions right and so you can now
play this game where you say let's
actually see what this definition does
in sort of more concrete market settings
and see if it does the right thing so
that's something i encourage you to do
pick your favorite market setting um
you look at performative power see if it
sort of does the thing you you expected
or wanted to do so we did this with
strategic classification um where we
make these standard assumptions and we
see how performance power plays out here
um and so the first thing we observed is
that a monopoly firm maximizes
performative power okay so if you just
have a single firm in your setup a
single predictor then participants are
willing to incur a cost equal to the
utility for the service so they're
willing to pay the full price for the
thing um at which point they basically
have like no no net no net utility for
the service because they expended
everything on like adjusting to your
model okay
the moment you introduce outside options
meaning there are exist firms that give
you some utility elsewhere
you're not willing to pay the full price
and so uh you know performative power
decreases
uh proportionally to how attractive your
outside options are
the more attractive the outside options
the less formative power you have
third when platforms actively compete
over users and users can switch between
firms
and these firms offer services that are
substitutes so let's say you're a
content creator and you know twitch and
youtube are equivalent for you you don't
care between them
then even two firms
give you zero performative power
the existence of two competing firms
with perfect substitutes give you zero
performance power what does that remind
you of
who remembers micro101
i don't know that's a competition but
yeah yeah yeah bertrand competition
that's exactly right yeah so uh okay
maybe it's just too easy for this
audience okay i'm uh no no no no
just a quick comment it seems that you
were assuming that there is kind of a
watch between the firm's incentive and
the consumer incentives i mean it could
be the case that if i have power i use
it in a way that increases surplus makes
customers happy so where is that
assumption here i just i don't see it
formally but yeah so a very good point
this gets at another fundamental point
that comes up with all measures of power
there's a difference between power and
like harm right exactly you know you
could be like highly performative
because you somehow were disruptive you
just had a better product right exactly
yeah and so like with all measures of
power there's like their step removed
from like arguing about harm to the
consumer right so and that's where you
know the features are relevant right
like you the features determine whether
or not they reflect harm
right
and so yeah i mean a firm could be
performative in a way that doesn't harm
the consumer that's a very good
observation okay yeah so this is
analogous with a virtual competition
where you'd like to firm simultaneously
set prices and if you set a price that
was a little bit too high like all the
users go to the other four all the
consumers go to the other firm and you
get nothing okay you have the same
phenomenon in performance prediction um
where you get zero performative power um
if uh if there are two competing firms
okay so these are like just some
theoretical properties to like convince
you that this is a reasonable definition
or suggest um but i would love to see
more work on this yeah i'm really
curious to understand the
performance power and the epsilon the
episodes
in that model that we had like so when
you said you were going to find
performance power i just
oh interesting yeah so does the epsilon
sensitivity give you a performance of
power that's a reward you're asking
exactly um
if you assume you start off from a state
right you're currently in a distribution
that's given by one of the model
parameters
uh then your performance power and
you're in within some l2 ball right
let's say your radius b
and you're epsilon sensitive then i
think your performance power is bound by
epsilon
that sound right yeah yeah so that's
that's important but yeah we don't uh
we've moved away from the epsilon
sensitivity
so then if you can predict so you said
that you could
get actually
with your um performance power movie
does that also mean that you can
actually have an idea of what your
distribution will be and like you can
learn the distribution and these
hypothetical scenarios when you're like
informed oh this is fascinating so
you're saying assume low performance
power doesn't retraining converge
exactly
interesting yeah i have to think about
it for a little bit
um
if you set up your distance function so
that gives you basically one way to get
that is if you set up your distance
function give you the sustain metric
yeah and use the low performance power
then it gives you like excellent
sensitivity and then you would get that
result right
does that sound
yeah yeah it's a little different
because it's a lift this condition
versus a soup but if you assume that
like the you know
basically you have a ball right and like
you're at the center and then the suit
gives you like
up to factor two like the
basically the
whole thing right
i think something like that something
like that could work but it's
interesting maybe this is like an
alternative to the epsilon sensitive you
assume low performance power and then
actually training convergence yeah
that's a that would be very nice result
okay cool so
since this has been burning on
everyone's mind um how do we go uh how
do we estimate this uh using causal
inference um so how do we go from causal
effects to performative power
i'm going to return to the yelp example
and uh i look up a paper by economist
anderson and magruder from 2012
where they did some regression
discontinuity and they argued that an
extra half star rating causes
restaurants to sell out 19 percentage
points more frequently almost 50 percent
more
um for just a single half star so if you
someone had like four stars instead of
like you know three and a half stars you
would get massively more uh business
how does that relate to performance
power
i argue that any such like causal effect
that our econ friends have been
surfacing of which there are many uh
actually leads to a lower bound of
performative power using like a nice
trick okay so remember we're looking at
the sort of supremum over possible
actions of the distance in these
counterfactual variables and so what you
can do is you can take this action f to
be yelp's action that perturbs the score
around the you know the the star
thresholds so like people who are just
on like 3.5 you like perturb it a little
bit
and you take zu to be the restaurants
the you know what you're interested in
like
wait time or number of customers and you
know whatever you're you're interested
like your measure of welfare for the
restaurant and then you can see
uh you know you plug that in and you can
basically repurpose this causal effect
that they have as a lower bound of
performance power
so you can say that you know your
performance power is at least as large
as you know the the effect of a single
half star rating
purely observational and in fact uh is
look at a paper and repurpose the
findings of the paper you don't even
really need to rerun anything
so this is like an observational design
okay you can generalize this and this is
what we call a display discontinuity
design um and it's based on this
observation that online platforms
display scores discretely okay so you
most platforms have some way of
discretizing their scores stars but also
ranking positions are really powerful
positioning is really powerful
ordering is really powerful coloring is
really powerful like rotten tomatoes red
or green right so you can think about
your favorite recommender system you'll
see that it has ways of discretizing
information
and any
causal effect of such display
discontinuities can be converted into a
lower bound of performance power so
whenever somebody went through the
effort of like let's say determining the
effect of like you know tweet ranking on
twitter right like how much does it help
you to be like the number one tweet on
the timeline versus the number two tweet
or somebody has determined how much of
an effect is there on youtube for the
first you know video on the left upper
left versus the
you know last video on the lower right
you know all of these are display
discontinuities suppose somebody
bothered to like experimentally or
otherwise figure out the causal effect
of display discontinuities you can
convert that into performance power
estimates
okay and the idea is just to take the
platform's action so as to swap items
around the discontinuity okay
since i'm out of time let me wrap up
this my last slide and then we can see
there are some more questions or i'll
take it offline um so classical
antitrust tools need market definitions
uh with specific uh you know kinds of
competition wired in uh they might need
equilibrium notions uh they might need
specific dynamics or assumptions about
uh firm behavior or user behavior
customer behavior and what performative
power does instead is it needs a
population definition
okay if you're the investigator you need
to put your finger on the population
where you expect the power relationship
to manifest okay so you as the
investigator specify units and features
where you suspect the power relationship
to become visible okay
and that's like an important step of the
investigation it's not sort of like an
abstract thing you can resolve that's
like context context specific
and the interpretation of the features
that you choose determines whether or
not the power is harmful or what how
much power you measure okay
so this is not entirely plug-and-play
you need to think carefully about how to
instantiate this
okay but the interesting thing here is
that sort of
uh low performance power is a conceptual
alternative to competition okay you can
like sort of try to lower about
performative power uh various ways and
if you kind of fail to like lower bound
perform the power that gives you like a
um
you know
a sense that there's competition
happening in some way or another either
people have outside options or they have
alternatives or there's
actively user switching and whatnot okay
so this is the way this logic goes again
i think it could be a helpful
uh complement to some of the existing
tools all right that's it thank you
um
i had a question about like if you if
you think about so the policy makers
policy the population uh response and
then in some sense like the policy maker
kind of responds to that can you think
about like a dual version of
performative power where instead i don't
know how to write this exactly i was
trying but maybe the soup is over the
distributions and then
um instead of having like an f on the
inside it's like f sub
distribution is that something that's
worthwhile to think about especially if
like you know maybe uber drivers like
you know
are working together to respond to a
pricing policy of uber no exactly
exactly right so the excellent question
um
so yeah two two things i mean first of
all this reminds me of paper tiana
co-authored on like where you switch the
order of like who goes first right and
you can think about that sort of has a
slightly different interpretation in
terms of power right like users or
consumers going first sort of says
they're in charge right and so you can
imagine like if people let's say do
collective action and they you know form
a union or whatever then you could they
might go first and yeah we're thinking
about we've been thinking about these
things in the in the context of
collective action where like if you know
all the users got together and said you
know we're the you know the restaurants
and yelp is messing with us so how
should we coordinate our move and then
you might get like a very different
dynamic and uh that's an interesting
instrument i'm happy to chat more
i have a question regarding the
observation you had from yelp i think
the observation was if you increase the
rating of a restaurant by half a star
given all of the restaurants are the
same i think you can increase the
purchase i don't know
of that restaurant something like that
is that correct i mean you assume that
all other restaurants are doing the same
and you increase the single restaurant
rating let's see what you think so
you're saying like you know uh the
causal effect was sort of meant to be
unilaterally right like if you leave
like star distributions
this this will be expectation of
maximum not maximum of experience you
need to be a little bit careful right so
this is a good point right so um
let's say you you increase everyone's
rating by a star right then somehow like
the distribution just you moved upwards
right so you can be a little bit careful
about how you do it so that like so my
question is how do you relate this
unilateral changes to performative power
how do you log around with these
observations how do you lower bound with
this observation yeah yeah i mean we we
have some unilateral causal effects and
you say that you can learn about
uh this performative power with these
observations but to me it's not clear
how do you use them because in
performative power in the calculation of
performative power
we need something general not not
unilateral maybe
yeah so i i see your point and it's very
good point so let's just repeat the
points you're saying um in performative
power you're doing an intervention it
affects all units so sort of like it
might have an effect on all the units in
this regression discontinuity that they
did they're just said like sort of the
effect they're interested in is like if
you increase like a single restaurant's
rating by half star you get this effect
yes you so you need to be if you
instantiate this you need to be careful
that you're not like
inflating you know the score
distribution right so you need to
somehow keep that keep that fixed and so
basically one way you can do this is by
swapping restaurants for instance around
the threshold
and then you're just like moving moving
business from one restaurant to another
oh hi um i have a question have you
heard of these
uh inference on counter factual
distributions it's this idea of
estimating a policy effect
uh like the marshall where you the
effect is the
change on the marginal distribution of
outcomes but you
consider a fixed distribution on the
covariate density so in relation to that
this kind of sounds like a data-driven
um
setting where the outcome is the change
in the covariate distribution but
presumably these could be combined
perhaps like the distribution on the
features
as well as the counter factual
distribution on the impacts and marginal
distribution of outcomes like wages for
example yeah yeah
i mean that sounds very interesting i
would love to hear more i mean like i
said there are all sorts of causal
designs that could be helpful here this
sounds like one that is relevant so uh
would be happy to to figure out how that
can be used here
yeah
just a quick a quick clarifying uh
question on your dunning example so in
that example you have two kind of
endogenous choices so one is restaurants
they adjust their standards quality
to the writing system and the other one
is that consumers
they have to figure out how to interpret
those ratings so if you try to pretend
that a one-star restaurant is a
five-star restaurant consumers right
will figure that out
so the the effect will be will be
different absolutely yeah yeah so yeah i
think you know um are you capturing both
uh with this notion or so basically what
you would have to do is what or what you
do is like you swap restaurants just
around the threshold and you assume that
you know restaurants that were scored
almost just like the same have like
similar qualities so the only thing that
changes is
the rating the half star rating
it wouldn't work if you like swapped
like a five star with a one that i
understand and i knew that paper but
then you know when you're thinking about
power of the firm you know
where is this captured like you can you
can do things at the threshold but not
too much because otherwise customers
will figure out
formally are you capturing this this
yeah district lining by again like it's
you would need the same assumptions that
you need for the regression discontent
when you design your action f you need
to make sure that you satisfy the
assumptions of the design so that's
that's what's going on good question
i think this question is where i got
confused before because i
went with the zfu question
because i was thinking that that was
somehow modeling the behavior of the
restaurants but i guess it wasn't
modeling the behavior of the restaurants
was modeling the behavior of the
consumers or the restaurant goers so the
model the behavior of the restaurants is
not at all part of your model or somehow
so yeah this is an interesting question
so when you um when you design like
introduce these counterfactual variables
right you're just saying there is some
kind of causal effect from my action
to the features
the mechanism is you know could be
anything right the mechanism could be uh
something that involves the restaurant's
behavior or it could be something that
involves the consumers
cf reviews could include for example
like the data that the restaurants
provide together right and you can look
at the changes that happen based on like
what that was yeah so that basically the
taxonomy of performativity in these like
recommended systems is a little bit more
complex than just this example right
there a lot of things you could
influence you could sort of like
influence what's on your platform you
can influence what's you know consumed
on your platform so there are different
there are different mechanisms that
determine performativity
um and so
you know it's a little bit like in a
grocery store right so you walk in
um the grocery store can rearrange the
items right um to like steer
consumers in a particular direction or
they could price items differently so
that suppliers either provide something
or don't right so you can kind of change
the supply side or the consumption side
and um
which of these mechanisms that i play
depends on what features we look at
and uh how what your action is right
um but it doesn't need the mechanism you
don't have to like model the mechanism
to
you know form introduce these beneficial
variables and maybe you know estimate
them from experiment
um but if you wanted to reason about it
theoretically yeah then you know some
such model might be helpful
so like we did in strategic
classification there we actually model
what you know the behavior is right
so yeah for the theory like if you want
to put stronger results about this you
might be the model and maybe you know
you'll even introduce a whole sort of
like market model right and then it's
like you could also evaluate other
notions
i think then you get back to the origin
of the question i had at the beginning
about you know distribution changing
response
you never got to the equilibrium between
the dna that's what i meant is just in
these uh strategic classification
setting the equilibrium is the stack of
vertical elements
um that's the sort of natural
equilibrium in that setting um and i was
i had a suspicion that that's what you
were getting at but maybe not
question in the sense like so very
finally
with the
this power i forgot the performative
power right so we are thinking about we
want to know how
this
institution this entity is able to
change the distribution rate so
there is so much in this choice of z
right
and i think there is a tension here like
when in the example you showed for the
yelp thing i think the example of the z
of you was like the waiting times on the
restaurants right
so i feel that this is also very likely
of being a future feature of the model
because
there's like those are concurrent
problems right because
people choose the features because they
think the features are describing the
problem well so
in real settings
they're probably going to be using all
the information they have
all right so there is attention here
and i'd like to know your opinion about
like how to reason about
that if you wanna i mean if you're
trying to be careful and causing all of
that
yeah yeah i know so i think you make a
good point that the features that you
look at disease are probably also
something that went into the
optimization of the platform um
previously but that's not necessarily uh
i don't see the tension it's just
something that can happen but yeah let's
say the wait times of restaurants
yesterday influenced my scores
and i'm looking at you know the wait
times under some hypothetical action
so i'm i you're right the opposite is
correct i just don't see
the tension so maybe we'll just kind of
discuss that a little bit more
cool
we should give people a break yes i
think that's it thank you so much again